and then on the privilege front this is
a really complicated one I think that
some of the guilt that the woke types
are capitalizing on and also genuinely
experiencing is a consequence of the
felt need for some true atonement
so you talked about Western privilege
and so you know if you live in the west
you're in the top one percent by global
and historical standards so you are
privileged and then you have to contend
with the fact that
well you didn't really
earn that not
to some degree because
your pathway forward is going to be
proportionate in its
success to your work but you know you're
born and there are highways and there
are Automobiles and there's an
electrical grid and you have this wealth
that's offered to you and then you might
say well that's unearned privilege and
to some degree it is and then the
question emerges well what should you do
about that and one answer is to
flagellate yourself and to feel guilty
because there are people out there who
weren't arbitrarily rewarded to the same
degree you were and that is an
existential problem and the other
solution is to
do whatever you can to earn your
earn the gifts you've been given the
talents you've been provided with right
and to say well my goal is to
justify by my actions the Privileges and
opportunities I have been granted and
then to work hard to extend those to the
degree that's possible to the people
around me and to others and I would say
that's genuine atonement and I think
everyone has to do that and so you know
if you're not living a life that's as
moral as you are privileged you're going
to lay yourself open on the guilt front
and then the woke ideologues are going
to tear a strip off you and certainly
these these kids that you've observed
flagellating themselves for their
privilege they don't know how to atone
for the fact that there is an unequal
distribution of talents and that seems
to be built into the cosmic structure
well that's why I felt it was so
important that someone told them that
and everything you said particularly
about how to
um how to respond to privilege it
resonates with me so much because I've
been you know my family's been destitute
my family's been very wealthy I've been
the son of a very rich family I've also
been someone who slept on the street for
weeks like I've seen both of those and
and what I learned from all of those
experiences is that like you said you
have to make the most of it and then
extend that opportunity to other people
um and and that's the only way of
dealing with it and there's no other way
um if you want to be constructive